and at this altitude I can run flat out
for a half-mile before my hands got
shaken the royalties were supported now
it is the cybernetic organism living
tissue over metal endoskeleton this
episode is brought to you by fresh books
back in 2003 a busy freelancer named
Mike McDormand I've actually had dinner
with accidentally saved over an invoice
and lost all this work to make sure that
never happened again
Mike's it out to create fresh books
which is now the number one cloud
accounting software designed exclusively
for self-employed professionals around
the world that is used by now 10 million
plus folks in total we need to send
invoices get paid fast and track their
time a lot of you fall in that category
in September of this year Mike and his
entire team relaunched an all new
version of their platform built from the
ground up double down on what made a
great in first place namely simplicity
and speed so I can't cover all the
features in this particular sponsor read
but you can set a branded invoice in
under 30 seconds
you can see what a client has looked at
their invoice and you can enable online
payments in two clicks if you need
customer support you will get a real
human being on the phone in three rings
or less and there many other things you
can do take pictures of receipts on your
phone using their iOS mobile app and
makes expenses of million times user etc
etc it is a rad service a lot of you
have recommended to me that's how this
came to be as a sponsorship so to claim
your 30-day unrestricted free trial that
means no credit card needed and see how
the brand-new FreshBooks can change your
freelancing game go to FreshBooks comm
forward slash Tim and enter Tim T I am
in the how did you hear about a section
that is first ebooks.com forward slash
tip
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront is a massively
disruptive in a good way set it and
forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash Kim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront as I mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low cost that were previously completely
impossible right off the bat you never
pay commissions or account fees for
everything they charge 0.25 percent per
year on assets above the first 15,000
which is managed for free if you use my
link wealthfront com4 / Tim that is less
than five dollars a month to invest a
thirty thousand dollar account for
instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on the show it's because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed
to here's the deal they wanted to
sponsor this podcast but because of SEC
regulations companies that invest your
money are not allowed to use client
testimonials so I couldn't be a user and
have them on the podcast but I've been
so impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
that account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim fast free there's no
downside that I can think of hello
ladies and germs this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show where it is my job each
episode to deconstruct world-class
performers of all different types from
entertainment to sports chefs military
and everything in between to tease out
the habits routines thought processes
decision-making processes that you can
use and test yourself this episode we
have a very very special treat and I
will say in advance we cover some very
very deep hard and also sensitive
material in this episode for some people
who listen to this it will be I think
the most important podcast episode you
ever listen to and that has nothing to
do with me it has everything to do with
the stories and lessons of Debbie
Millman at Debbie Millman on Twitter and
elsewhere you can say hello is quote one
of the most influential designers
working today and quote by graphic
design USA she is also the founder and
host of design matters which is the
world's first and longest-running
podcast about design she's interviewed
nearly 300 design luminaries and
cultural commentators including Massimo
Vignelli Milton Glaser with an F and
remember that name he will come back her
artwork has been exhibited around the
world she's designed everything from
wrapping paper to beach towels greeting
cards to playing cards notebooks to
t-shirts and if you've heard of say Star
Wars while she worked on the
merchandising Burger King the redesign
Hershey's Tropicana at one point if you
walked into any given grocery store or
say supermarket anything like that she
had a hand in about 20% of everything
you might see or touch she is the
present
emeritus of AIGA one of five women to
hold that position in the organization's
100-year history she has six books that
she is authored and in 2009 that he
co-founded with Stephen Heller the
world's first master's program in
branding at the School of Visual Arts in
New York City where I've spent some time
now in its eighth year the program has
achieved international acclaim we cover
a lot we cover facing rejection
overcoming personal and professional
crises of faith and this is one of the
most powerful conversations that I've
ever had on this podcast so without
further ado please enjoy and think hard
on reflect on this conversation with
Debbie Millman Debbie welcome to the
show
Thank You Kim it's really wonderful to
be here I have wanted to interview you
on numerous occasions now over the last
few years so I'm thrilled is that we are
finally doing this point number one and
I thought I would start with a question
that someone like yourself who has
explored so many different things in so
many different formats when someone asks
you what do you do let's say you meet
someone at a party to say what do you do
what is your answer to that that's a
tough question um what do I say well I
now I say that I'm a designer and
sometimes if I'm feeling wordy I'll say
that I'm a designer and a writer and a
podcaster and sometimes people look at
me like huh like huh - really - so what
does that mean exactly
I found when I was working at sterling
brands which I did for over two decades
I had resolved - just saying when I was
filling out what I did on passport
applications in this and things like
that I used to say executive and that
made sense so now that it is a great
catch-all you executive is a great
catch-all for a long time on Twitter I
had Debbie Millman as a girl until
enough people say
Debbi really got to change that and and
then I did the Internet well you can put
anything there and I think about 10% of
the people who come across it will be
outraged for one reason or another oh
yes I found that the very things that
delight and excite some people are the
same exact things that outraged others
it's really hard to please everybody all
the time yeah I think that if you try to
please all the people all the time
you'll just end up displeasing yourself
all the time
let's see that's the only guarantee that
would come there no Jim I learned that
the hard way
well I want to talk about so many things
Debbie but let's start with and for
those people wondering I always ask my
guests beforehand is there any
particular say prompts for stories that
we could explore that might be fun to
dig into and one of them was drawing you
did when eight years old and so I know
nothing about this and I just want to
start there since it seems to make sense
to begin at the beginning well I have a
somewhat of a packrat mentality I keep
things I am I'm a sentimentalist at
heart and I like to keep things from all
different stages of my life and I have
boxes of journals and drawings and all
sorts of board cards and you name it I
have it well apparently I got this
straight from my mother who a couple of
years ago did what a lot of good old
Jews do she moved from Queens New York
to Florida the great migration he said
and before she moved she unloaded
several boxes of ephemera of mine that
she had kept unbeknownst to me and I
went through everything quite gingerly
was all sort of folded up very neatly
and very tightly and came across an
illustration that I did when I was about
8 years old and after I admired my
handiwork because I thought wow 8 years
old I was I was like rocking the
drawings I realized
said that this particular drawing had
predicted my whole life and and so I
will explain I will try to explain this
drag as best as I can and for some
backstory I am a native New Yorker I was
born in Brooklyn when I was about 2
years old my parents took me to Howard
Beach Queens I moved there before there
were any sidewalks that that will give
you a little bit of a sense of how old I
am I lived there until I was about I was
in the middle of a third grade and we
moved to Staten Island and I lived on
Staten Island until I was in the fifth
grade and the fifth grade my parents got
divorced my mom took my brother and I to
and he stood half years younger than I
am to Long Island my childhood was spent
in almost all of the borough's except
Manhattan and for some reason I had a I
guess a sense of what Manhattan looked
like and felt like probably from
television and at eight years old I draw
I drew a picture of the streets of
Manhattan I'm walking I'm a little girl
I'm walking along with my mother my
mother by the way is wearing a very
popular Barbie outfit of the time an
outfit called tangerine dream which I
really loved
I put her in that outfit and and despite
not having a lot of time on the street
or any time on the streets of Manhattan
i I drew it quite in quite good detail
there were buildings and buses and taxis
and I labeled everything I labeled the
cleaners cleaners and I labeled the bank
bank and I labeled the taxi taxi in the
middle of the street there is a delivery
truck and I not only labeled the
delivery truck I also drew the sign on
the delivery truck and the sign was
Lay's potato chips
I drew the logo at eight years old and
when I saw this
crying I realized that I had predicted
my whole life I'm a native New Yorker
now living in Manhattan I've been living
in Manhattan for 33 years I go to the
bank I go to the cleaner they take lots
of taxis lots of buses and at the time I
found this drawing I was drawing logos
for a living and and you know had I
known that it would have been that easy
just to follow that drawing I would have
saved decades of experiments in failure
and rejection so this this is is
fascinating to me for a number of
reasons I've had a few guests on the
podcast Chris Sacca would be another
example as an investor and he at some
point wrote and journal well I think it
was one of these composition notebooks
with the observes model black and white
zebra / camouflage covers I left that
what he would be when he was 40 years
old and he must have done this when he
was 10 or 12 something like that and he
found it in his I think his parents
garage later around the age of 42 or
something like that and it also
predicted effectively exactly what he
would be doing but it was lost in the
slipstream and he took this very
meandering in some ways odd seemingly
fractured paths to come right back to
where he started in the sense did you
then it sounds like you didn't follow
that plan that had was so neatly
summarized in this picture because there
are folks out there say you know when I
was five I knew I always want it to be X
but what was your or should I say when
did you figure out that you wanted to
actually do what wasn't that drawing on
some level that you weren't to be a
designer I actually never set out to be
a designer I thought that I was going to
be a journalist the only thing that I
knew for sure when I was in college was
that when I graduated I wanted to live
in Manhattan at that point I had not
ever lived in Manhattan and that was my
big dream
and I came to an hat in the summer of
1983 I often say that that was the
summer of David Bowie's modern love and
the police's synchronicity I saw those
concerts that summer I moved into a
sublet apartment with a friend that had
also recently graduated she had found a
sublet on the corner of Hudson and Perry
streets in the village I didn't know it
at the time but moving into an apartment
on the intersection of Hudson and Perry
was almost as if I was entering the
movie Gidget goes to Manhattan I didn't
know where I was going I it was quite
serendipitous my friend Jay found the
apartment for us unfortunately that
wonderful summer turned out rather
unfortunate because the woman who Jay
and I were subletting from was rather
than paying the rent with the rent money
that she was getting from us was keeping
it and not paying the rent so at the end
of the summer we all got evicted and it
was yeah I ended up appealing to the
landlord to please please help me find
someplace else to live because I really
didn't have any place else to go
and he ended up being able to rent me
another one of the apartments he had in
another building he owned on 16th Street
which was a fourth floor tenement
walk-up a railroad flat that I couldn't
afford on my own and ended up living
with a couple room my roommates were a
couple because it was a railroad flat I
had to walk through the apartment which
meant through their bedroom to get to
mine which often meant I was stuck on
one side or the other depending on their
nocturnal habits our afternoon July
depending on you know what they were
doing and and live there for about five
years before I ended up moving back into
the village for a short period of time
so that was the one thing I knew that I
wanted to live in Manhattan I did not
know that I could
that I would be a designer and wear that
design was even a discipline until my
senior year of college I had worked my
way up to be the editor of the arts and
feature section of this student
newspaper at SUNY Albany where I went to
school and realized very quickly that as
much as I loved assigning articles and
coming up with themes for this section
of the newspaper I was endlessly
fascinated by putting the paper together
by designing the paper and thus a baby
designer was born I took all of one
class in design while I was in in
college and really learned almost
everything I knew at that time working
in the newsroom putting the paper
together everything was done old school
way outpaced of computing machine stat
cameras and then when I graduated was
both doing freelance editorial and
freelance layout and paced up for the
first couple of years of my career when
did you start at the student isn't that
something you started at the very
beginning and follows throughout your I
guess undergrad experience interesting
and perceptive question Tim I wanted to
write for the student newspaper I think
the very first issue I saw when I got to
SUNY Albany freshman year and went up to
the student newspaper which was on the
third floor of the Campus Center and
approached the editor at the time and
asked if I could be a writer or offered
my services volunteered my my my
services and he looked at me and asked
me if I had any klimt and I was like you
know I didn't say what I was thinking
but like hair clips I'm here I don't
know what I'm talking about
and I didn't have anything and I didn't
know what to do when I was embarrassed
and humiliated and ashamed and sort of
squirrels
you know scurried away and didn't go
back until my junior year I was so
I'm intimidated by the talent and the
work that was coming out of that
newsroom and it was at the time and very
well may still be one of the best
student newspapers in the country and I
came up twice a week Tuesdays and
Fridays and I would I was just enamored
with this newspaper and I fantasized
about writing really pissy area diet
letters to the editor in chief that
would then get published in you know the
letters to the editor section and they
would realize what a great writer I was
and then invite me to be a reporter and
I sort of walk around like Rosalind
Russell with a pencil behind my ear and
my heels click clacking in the newsroom
and of course that never happened I
never wrote one letter to the editor and
for some reason and I guess an aberrant
moments of courage I went back up to the
newsroom my second semester junior year
and there was a women's uprising at the
studio where the Student Health L foods
George don't like could you go cover
that and I was like yeah absolutely and
I went and did it and that was how I
started writing for the paper I then
wrote a piece about an exhibit in the
Art Center and by the end of my second
semester junior year only what I think
no one else would take it I was offered
the job of being editor of the Arts in
feature section and began that that
summer that senior year in college was
one of the most exciting and best years
of my life in that for the first time
ever I felt like I had purpose suddenly
working on this paper I felt like I was
something I was part of something bigger
than myself I felt like I was had some
reason for being and I loved learning
about design I loved being able to work
with writers and I felt for the first
time in my life really excited about
something I want to talk about that a
buret moment
courage and dig into that a bit so you
were rejected from or maybe you rejected
yourself or both initially when you're
approached the paper then years later
you have this aberrant moment of courage
what precipitated that there a
conversation a realization you watched a
movie what triggered that do you
remember um I actually don't I wish that
I did it would make it from much better
story and certainly a better interview
but I what I can tell you is that all
these years later I have noticed a
pattern in my life of being very easily
hurt by an initial reaction or an
initial rejection so much so that it
sorts any other attempt at making
something like that happen for a very
long time I am extremely sensitive and
any rejection sort of takes me off of
that path for quite a long time it takes
me a while to recover he's given you
examples of that I would say my entire
life and I will give you I can give you
forty three examples get comfortable Tim
I'm done bumps I'm just yeah I'm
definitely settling in with my water I'm
ready to go well there I was rejected
that first year of college took me than
three years to go back again I might
have been feeling confident about
something else that had gone well in my
life and thought what the heck why not
go back and try and and then put those
steps up to the campus center and went
back up to the third floor and asked
again I
and somebody that has a very hard time
taking no for an answer but it takes me
a long time to recalibrate and get my
courage back to continue to keep trying
and when I graduated because I had such
a hard time finding a job initially that
I really loved and because I was having
so much trouble figuring out what I
wanted to do with my life
I kept bouncing around from opportunity
to opportunity and every time I would
try something new and would ultimately
get rejected
I used that first rejection almost as a
permission slip to avoid having to try
again so when I graduated I I started
working at a couple of different
newspapers I got me some magazines that
work for cable magazine and I worked for
a rock magazine giving layout and paste
up and some editing and at the time
thought oh I'm really enjoying this but
I don't really feel qualified to be
doing this maybe I should go back to
school and get a masters degree in
journalism and I lived in the
neighborhood of a very good journalism
school the Columbia School of Journalism
and my dad had gone to Columbia and
study pharmacy and I thought why not
apply to the Columbia School of
Journalism but that was the only school
I applied to I thought you know I want
to consider getting a master's degree in
journalism there are a lot of good
journalism schools in New York City but
for some reason I had my heart set on
this one school I didn't get in I got
rejected and abandoned my hopes or dream
of going to get a master's degree in
journalism shortly thereafter because I
also in the painter I had been accepted
into a show at Long Island University
the Brooklyn campus and got some good
reviews and thought soon maybe I should
become an artist I I love doing this I'm
getting some good response from it but I
don't feel qualified or or educated
enough maybe I should get an advanced
degree in art and I applied to the
Whitney School the Whitney Museum of Art
had an independent study program that
would allow me to continue working
during the day I apply for that I had
really good references wonderful clips
at that point you know some good reviews
and got rejected to that and then
abandoned that dream and so it's been a
long history of making an attempt
getting that early rejection retreating
and then finally sort of licking my
wounds reen sort of knitting my
confidence or hopes and dreams together
and then trying to do something else or
trying again so few questions the first
is what would you have what would you
say to your college self after that
first rejection at the newspaper or what
advice would you give someone who had
the near-identical experience and was
hardwired the same way well it's an
interesting question Tim because I have
the benefit of hindsight and looking
back on those years yes I certainly
could have tried again sooner and maybe
had more of a runway to experiment and
grow and learn in that newsroom and in
that environment but I also think that
those years in between learning and
growing in other ways contributed to my
ability to then when appointed the
editor of the arts and Features section
I somehow had a lot more to pull from
and maybe this is my own sort of
synthesizing happiness or calibrating to
my own set point or looking back and
thinking well it all sort of worked out
so why give somebody advice that I
wouldn't have necessarily taken at that
point what I what I would say is
don't accept the first rejection ever
give yourself options the timeliness of
those options or the timeliness of those
retries do at your own pace you don't
you're not in competition with anybody
but yourself
so if you are rejected to something that
you want then think about what it is
that caused that rejection and work to
better understand how you can present
your best possible self when you try
again and your your clips mention when
you're like Clips hair clips remind
reminded me of a story I heard when I
was a student so you work with a lot of
students we're going to come back to
that
okay can I add one more thing before I'm
sorry is this isn't interesting you can
add many things please so one thing that
I that I haven't shared about this
particular story is that the man that
the young man that rejected me that
first year if somebody that I have that
I then befriended in that experience of
working at the paper that junior year
and I graduated in 1983 it is now 2017
and I have been friends with that man
his name is Robert Edelstein I have been
friends with him ever since so just
because somebody rejects you doesn't
mean that they don't like you first of
all he didn't even reject me he asked me
for a very reasonable yes me for
something very reasonably ask me for
some examples of my writing I was so
intimidated and was so embarrassed by
not knowing exactly what he meant in the
fact that I didn't have anything other
than something from high school which I
didn't feel her bro priyad that I was
the one that rejected myself in many
ways one of the interesting things that
I have found is
and Rob is not the only person that I
can point to as being somebody that
initially provided some sort of obstacle
or roadblock
that was a reasonable one and then
ultimately I befriended and we become we
are now lifelong friends he didn't even
remember rejecting me that freshman year
and is mortified now by the notion that
he might have done anything to hurt my
feelings
so one of the other things that I would
suggest that people consider if they
believe they are being rejected is
considered what the perception from the
other person doing the rejection or the
supposedly ejection might be and that
sense of empathy might be really helpful
in understanding where you're coming
from what you're bringing to that
specific example or that that specific
experience and I'd like to underscore
this because it's such an important
point and I in some respects like you
have been very sensitive I still am in
some respects very sensitive and my
particular brand of that or my
particular type of response is to feel a
some type of sense of injustice and and
so I will get rejected and looking back
at what I see is a rejection either when
I did this brush ten years ago I looked
at a number of instances or I felt like
I've been rejected via email and so on
that a it wasn't a rejection for all
time it wasn't not now it was it was a
very temporary impossibility due to
logistics and I took that as a no not
ever and felt very hurt by that and
didn't try a second time in many cases
yeah a little absolutely so number one
you know may just mean no not right now
and you can even clarify that right you
can ask that as a clarifying question
number two is that at some point someone
said to me and this doesn't apply to
your particular instance but don't don't
ascribe to malice
can be described what can be explained
by incompetence and that didn't cover it
all for me though but it really made a
profound impact on me when I when I was
told this and because I would read email
with inserting if I were doing an
audiobook of the other person's voice
some type of really angry upset person
and nine times out of ten that wasn't
the tone at all I was just I was miss
reading it and so I started to assume
for myself don't ascribe to malice what
can be explained by incompetence or just
busyness the person is busy if they send
you a really short response to your mini
novellas an email it doesn't mean that
they think you're worthless or not worth
their time it could just mean that they
have ten times more to do than you do
and it's sometimes hard to have that
perspective when particularly you're
starting out and you're you're a bit
fragile and you're unwell blue legs and
you send this huge outpouring of your
emotion to someone you respect and then
they respond with sorry kid not right
now and you're like yeah that's it and
then yeah I I'm not going to name names
but there's someone who now I'm very
close friends with extremely well
respected writer and I got one of these
one-line responses in two thousand five
or six when I sent an early manuscript
of the 4-hour workweek to this person
via email and the response was
effectively thanks but sorry I don't
have time to read this right now
no dear Kim no signature just one line
and I felt so slighted by this that I
held this subconscious grudge for years
and now we're really good friends and
the whole thing's ludicrous in
retrospect one thing that I find about
human nature is that ambiguity is always
perceived negatively so there might be
nothing in that one-line email that
would be in any way disparaging or
insulting or or anything but because we
as humans perceive ambiguity ambiguity
negatively we tend to read into things
that aren't there in a way that makes us
feel bad but I also think that a lot of
that for me comes from having a very
sort of fragile Center and
not necessarily thinking that they are
specifically upset with me because of
something that I've done but just
because everything that I do is is sort
of bad they're just real they're just
they're just cognizant of that so it's
not something specific as to something
all-encompassing and so that's that's
been something I've been struggling to
overcome over the decades so I have few
questions about how you came to find
your niche or the first time you clicked
into place so to speak doing something
that resembles what what you ended up
doing up to this point but before I get
to that just to just to put a button in
the the anecdote related to clip so you
mentioned clip static lips hair clothes
I was told the story by a professor in
college about Nantucket nectars when I
was just getting started and there I
believed two guys who were really faking
it until they made it in a lot of
respects and at one point their meeting
with this distributor because they had
been selling these these concoctions via
boats in Nantucket from boat to boat to
boat and they wanted to go into retail
and it met with this is either retailer
distributor was early on and and they
were really nervous and the muckety-muck
they were meeting with at least in their
eyes said are you good do you have a lot
of POS mature and they looked at each
other like oh [ __ ] and they said oh POS
were all about POS yeah he's like good
good good and then they walked up like
what the hell is POS point-of-sale I
which of course you know plenty about
but the wanted to too before we get to
when you first clicked into your your
niche and how that happened you
mentioned knowing that you wanted to be
in Manhattan and I've been thinking a
lot about the components of and this is
a dangerous word sometimes but
- and that often times we think of the
let's say the journalist w's write the
interrogative the why the what the where
and so on happiness and I think humans
tend to at least put why at the top then
maybe what some were lower and then
where is often an afterthought but I've
started to believe that the where is
more is much more critical than we give
it credit for and that you can you can
actually start there so I thought about
this a lot for myself but really the how
important the geography can be because
it determines in large measure who
you're surrounded with all the time and
what you're surrounded with all the time
but I guess it's more of an observation
than a question but how do you if you've
ever if you think about that how do you
think about the components of up
happiness or well-being for yourself
that's a big big question Tim Cory oh
well this sort of two parts to the
question I think and the first is this
notion of New York sort of being the
place that I wanted to be and what I
told myself at that time and then
ultimately how that leads to happiness
or fulfillment and one of the things
that I struggled with when I first moved
to Manhattan or when I first graduated
really was what was I going to be what
was I going to do I didn't have a lot of
money I didn't have any network and I
certainly didn't have any type of
connection to any ends or apartments or
jobs or anything like that and I wanted
very badly to be in Manhattan that was
something that I knew for sure in
thinking about what I wanted with my
life I knew that I wanted to do
something creative one of my big hopes
and dreams at that time was to work at
Conde Nast and I did apply and I did get
a call back and I got rejected and then
never tried again and
for example of that but one of the more
high altitude aspirations was either
being an artist or being a writer so
being more of a fine artist and not a
commercial artist but at the time I did
not think that my chances of success at
that would either be possible and
certainly if it were possible not fast
and because I wanted to live in New York
City because I wanted to live in
Manhattan I felt that I needed to be
able to get a job that would pay my rent
and because I didn't want to be a
waitress and because I didn't want to be
a bartender I needed to make some type
of reasonable income in order to pay
that rent and so I have been telling
myself for decades now that I decided
that I needed to work as a designer
because I needed to have some sort of
income that would give me some sense of
self-sufficiency self-sufficiency has
been enormous ly important to me and
I've said that for years and years and
years and that being safe and secure and
being able to manage the course of my
own life having financial stability with
something that was a bit of a lead gene
for me in making the decisions that I
did and back in that summer of David
Bowie and the police I remember coming
home from a club one night and I was on
the corner of Bleecker Street and 6th
Avenue and it suddenly occurred to me
that I had to make a decision and the
decision was what was I going to do and
I realized that if I wanted to be an
artist or a writer that I would likely
have to take some type of job that would
not necessarily be able to safeguard
what I considered to be my financial
future
therefore made this little pact with
myself in my head that I would become a
designer so that I could make enough
money to be able to be secured and I've
been telling myself that for decades
what I realized in the last couple of
years was that I was unbeknownst to my
psyche my my consciousness I was lying
to myself I was absolutely positively
lying to myself because more than the
self-sufficiency was the desire to be in
Manhattan
I couldn't easily become or more easily
become an artist or a fine artist or a
writer if I didn't want to live in the
most expensive city in the world I could
have gone and lived with my mother in
Queens I could have lived with friends
and Albany I could have had seven
roommates in in a little commune in
bed-stuy there would have been any
number of things that I could have done
if my lead gene had been artistic purity
but no I told myself that it was because
of X Y & Z but really what it was was
the most important thing to me at that
point in my life was being in Manhattan
and I lived in a fourth fourth fourth
floor tenement walk-up I had to walk
through somebody else's bedroom to get
to mine I was living on the floor with
people that were constantly the other
tenants in the building were locking
each other out it was an elderly couple
and they were always fighting there were
a whole family of pigeons living on the
fire escape outside of my window in my
bedroom which was so decrepit I couldn't
even open the window in the summertime
and there was no air conditioning in
this apartment I mean the conditions
that I lived in were deplorable but yet
that was the most important thing to me
so when I talk to people now about what
do they want to do when they first
graduate I ask them to think about what
is the one most important
thing to you what is the one most
important thing to you because if it is
truly the one most important thing to
you you will likely do whatever it takes
to get it and the most important thing
to me was not being a writer and it was
not being and not being an artist it was
living in Manhattan and I did whatever
it took and lived in whatever conditions
that I needed to in order to make that
happen
I think it's a really important
realization oh definitely and see you by
hook or crook you're living in Manhattan
yet that is the the outcome in part of
all these decisions and the lead gene as
you put it where does the the need for
for stability security or the desire for
that come from well I do think that it's
it's certainly in Maslow's hierarchy of
needs a really important one for me it
takes on think any an extra level of
significance in that I grew up in a
really really challenging environment so
my parents got divorced when I was very
young I was about eight years old and I
I had a very very complicated
relationship with my father my father
died last year unexpectedly
my father sort of in my daughter eyes
was brilliant charismatic he was an
incredibly well-spoken man he was also
extremely turbulent he had a lot of
anger issues and over the course of our
lives together
I had five different experiences with
him where he rejected me and decided
that he didn't want me in his life and
so one of those periods was about nine
years so we had a very very turbulent
relationship when my parents got
divorced
I told myself at the time that I was
really happy about that because I was so
scared of his anger and so scared of the
anger that they had for each other about
a year after my parents got divorced my
mother married again and she married a
man who was physically and sexually
abusive to me physically abusive to my
brother and also sexually abusive to his
to biological to one of his two
biological daughters and was and and
severely severely beat us for for four
years during that time was one of the
times the first time actually that I was
estranged from my biological father and
so I had a lot of brutality in my life
and after they got divorced I was 13 my
father came back into my life my mother
then got involved with another another
man who was ten years younger than her
so therefore only ten years older than
me and was also I guess I'll put it
sexually provocative with me and also
emotionally abusive so for the first
like 18 years of my life I lived in a
state of constant terror and compensated
or self-soothe but with art with a lot
of extracurricular activities in school
I was always an overachiever probably in
an effort to prove to myself and to my
family that I wasn't worthy of the abuse
that was being inflicted on me I wanted
so much more for my life even back then
and grew up thinking that if I had the
resources to take care of myself that I
would never allow anything bad to happen
to me not not quite a realistic
expectation but but was something that I
felt was possible to do of course it's
not that takes decades to also figure
out but at that time I wanted very badly
to be able to live in my own home
to be able to take care of myself and to
be in a position where I would never be
vulnerable again you know sort of
Scarlett O'Hara I'm never going to go
hungry again
yeah it doesn't always work out that way
but it was definitely the journey that
that I've been on well thank you for
sharing that I had no idea and it's not
something I talk about a lot mostly
because I've had an enormous amount of
shame about it and and that's a very
normal thing and I still do and it's
still very very hard for me to share
these types of things but I do think
it's important that people do see that
there is hope for a better life even
when you are the victim of these types
of situations I've spent a lot of time
working on better integrating those
experiences into my life in a way to not
only understand what happened why it
happened what the aftermath then caused
but also how I can use that empathy and
that understanding to try to help the
world and that's a lot of the reason
that I started to do the work that I do
with Mariska Hargitay and the joyful
Heart Foundation which is a foundation
that
Marishka started after she started
working on law and order SVU shortly
after she started working on that
television program she started to
receive a lot of letters from people
that the very very victim she was trying
to find justice for on the television
show and realized that this is way more
than a television show
is a huge opportunity to make a
difference in our culture and shortly
thereafter started the joyful Heart
Foundation which is an organization to
help eradicate domestic violence sexual
assault and child abuse and I've been
working with Marishka and Marley's and
boutot the CEO of the foundation now for
the last five years and this work
I believe the branding work that I've
been able to do with them taking into
all the expertise I've had in
repositioning and branding some of the
biggest CPG companies in the world and
now dub telling that with my own
background really truly makes me feel
like my whole life makes sense Tim
that's beautiful and I'm really glad
you're talking about this because I can
imagine a very different experience but
I've had my own battles with darkness of
different types and it's very easy to
believe that you are alone or isolated
or that things will never change
and I'm sure there are people listening
who have had similar experiences to
yours who have never talked about them
or have never found a way to perhaps
integrate or reconcile them and this
might be an incredible catalyst for them
I would love to ask if you're open to
talking about it for yourself have you
found any particular avenues or types of
work to be particularly helpful to you
of course the the work that you're doing
with the joyful heart foundation but
apart from that is are there any
particular types of exercises or work or
anything really it has helped you to be
more at peace with your experience I
think that the work that I've done in
therapy has saved my life I have always
been
really dedicated to my therapy and have
been in therapy with the same analyst
now for over two decades
what type of therapy is that if you
don't let me asking I know very little
about um she I think well she is the
person who I work with is a PhD she was
very involved in the psychoanalytic
community in New York City she's now
living in Santa Fe I think that it's a
combination of a number of different
philosophies and theories probably at
its foundation psychoanalysis but but
certainly with quite a lot of variations
um it's talk therapy I started back in
the early 90s five days a week and then
moved down to three days and now I'm
usually two or three days and it is
enormous ly helpful to help me try to
make sense of these experiences that
I've had for anybody that is either in
the midst of experiencing them or
experiencing the aftermath there is a
lot of there are a lot of resources one
of the things that I experienced when I
was in the midst of these experiences
was a sense of profound aloneness the
experiences that I had the worst
experiences I had were in the 70s
and at the time the topic wasn't one
that was as understood I didn't know
what was happening to me I thought I was
the only person in the world that this
was happening to because it seemed so
surreal and unnatural and punishing
it didn't occur to me that this was
pervasive that this was a cultural
epidemic and I was told at the time by
the perpetrator that if I told anybody
that he had the resources to hurt my
brother and my mother that he would kill
them horrible and I believed that I was
a little girl I believe that and I was
protecting them and I didn't know that I
had any other resources none and didn't
even tell my mother until after they got
divorced
but this Tamil I didn't want to be the
reason I didn't want to be blamed and I
also didn't think anybody would believe
me and I didn't want my mother and my
brother to be harmed it wasn't until I
was much older that I realized that this
was pervasive and so for anybody that is
listening if you feel alone know that
you're not you can go to the joyful
Heart Foundation the joyful Heart
Foundation org and there are resources
and phone numbers you can also go to No
More org which is another organization
that I've helped and there are resources
and people that are there to help and
listen and get you out of the situation
that you are in thank you for that to
insert some levity I'm not sure how to
segue from here but I will well let's
talk about some of the really really
important things that that people are
doing now to not only eradicate this
type of violence but also to change the
world one of the other things that
joyful heart is doing that I am so proud
of is ending the backlog there are
hundreds of thousands of rape kits
that are not being investigated that are
sitting in shelves in Police
Department's all over the country and so
the joyful hearts foundation along with
Vice President Joe Biden
been very involved in getting funding to
help analyze those rape kids to be able
to analyze the DNA and get serial
rapists off the streets
and guess and get justice for the
victims of those crimes so that's a
really really important thing that
they're doing and something that I feel
can ultimately change not only the sort
of rape culture that we're living in but
also the blaming a victim so we can
change culture by doing this work
together it's something I'm super proud
of and to those people listening all of
these resources that are being mentioned
throughout this episode will be in the
show notes
so you can certainly find links to know
more now nor the joyful Heart Foundation
and so on at four hour work week on for
Tosh podcast all spelled out maybe I'd
love to ask you to shift gears just a
little bit or perhaps a lot a Speak Up
story it's one of my favorite stories I
will let you run with it I shall love
for you to I would love for you to share
okay so so I want to start this story by
letting people know that this was
something that while it was happening I
thought was the worst professional
experience of my life
and it's turned out to be the most
important and life-affirming of my life
so so let me tell you a little bit about
the Speak Up story so the year is 2003
and the time of in the world was was
quite different than it is now so we
were we were online but we weren't quite
online in the way that we are now I
think YouTube was just just just
beginning it was a video sharing site
more than anything we were online but we
were playing games and we were ordering
from the j.crew catalog i don't know if
people remember when they j.crew catalog
went online people's heads exploded you
could buy things online
and they could be shipped to you you
don't have to leave the house oh my god
is so amazing and we were playing like
we were playing games and we were
emailing and reading the news and and
they were forums where people would
congregate but they tended to be more
niche forums and and not so much
mainstream cultural forums prior to that
leading up to that time in my life I had
joined sterling brands in 1995 and this
was one of the first moments of that
click that you had mentioned earlier
where suddenly without even realizing it
I had joined a firm where I was hired to
help grow the business via the
acquisition of new clients in branding
and the job was one of the first times
in my life where I was almost
effortlessly successful I think because
of my early childhood in my father's
pharmacy being surrounded by brands I
had and my own sort of obsession with
things like Lay's potato chips
yes exactly I had this almost magical
ability to understand why and how people
chose the objects that they did to be
part of their lives mostly the brands
that they chose so I started working at
Sterling brands and had this heretofore
unbelievable level of success
financially and I really enjoyed it
I am also endlessly fascinated by the
choices people make for the objects in
their lives what they choose to surround
themselves with the kinds of things they
buy and share and eat and wear and so
forth and in as much as I loved what I
was doing and as much as I was relishing
the level of success that in my early
30s I was
finally finally getting I also was still
sort of longing for that artistic
creative sort of part of my life that I
felt was was deeply missing at that
point what department were you working
in I was working in marketing and what
else got it so I wasn't I wasn't at that
time doing very much design work I was
doing some work freelance I had been
appointed the off-air creative director
at hot 97 which is a whole other sort of
story to share some point but I was I
was working to develop the identity and
the graphics for the first ever hip hop
radio station which happened to be in
New York and was called hot 97 that was
the only thing that I was doing on the
side I started working at Sterling
brands and was longing for a design
community and was longing for a feeling
of being part of something bigger than I
was on my own but something that was
much more creative and had no commercial
implications and I found the AIGA the
American Institute of graphic arts and
they had a special interest group within
AIGA called the brand experience center
and I was so excited I thought oh my god
this is a Venn diagram of my life I can
be branding and they they have designers
and and all these famous designers are
on the board and I could meet them and I
could be part of this great community
and so I went and I volunteered and I
became a member of AIGA and I was
working with this brand experienced
group and I loved it and I was appointed
to the board and I felt really really
part of something and the board term was
I think two years and at the end of the
term we if we wanted to be on the board
again we all had to reapply and in that
two years I was very active I went to
all the meetings and we weren't funded
by AIGA we had to self fund and so I
made cupcakes for bake sales and we had
a flea market and I was very
very involved in this sort of day-to-day
runnings of this little special interest
group at the end of the two years we all
had to reapply if we want to be on the
board again and every single person
reapplied and every single person was
appointed on the board again except me
so I I was risking you how you set me up
like they were really good cupcakes and
brownies and and I was devastated I was
just devastated and Rick Rifai who has
been the executive director he had been
aware of how much I wanted to be in a
IgA and how much I wanted to do and my
aspirations and I think he felt really
bad for me asked me if I wanted to have
lunch and he took me to a very expensive
lunch at 11:00 Madison and over the
course of one yeah it was super
wonderful and generous of him over the
course of lunch he said please please
don't give up on a IgA we need people
like you and don't give up we'll find a
place for you I promise and I guess is a
bit of a consolation prize he asked me
if I would be a judge in the upcoming
annual competition that AIGA had called
365 and he asked me if I wanted to be a
judge in the package design category
this to me was almost worth being kicked
to the curb by this special interest
group of the Brent experience I did this
was like the biggest honor of my career
at that point to be a judge in the
country's biggest design competition was
unfathomable to me it felt like a
miracle and so I went to the judging and
there were two other judges with me we
had seven hundred entries that we needed
to look at in one day and when I got to
the to the judging at AIGA headquarters
I met with the other two jurors one was
a very well-known designer who had a bit
of a boutique agency very posh she was
very stylish I did not feel nearly as
stylish
another guy was there from Apple and
this was shortly after the
iPod had been released and he was on his
iPod the whole time and really didn't
spend a lot of time paying attention to
the judging in any cases other juror is
whether what a dick yes anyway the other
guy I don't know yeah in the Jura looks
at me when I get there just like just so
you know I don't intend to have any
mass-market packaging in this
competition get an award and I was like
okay and I didn't agree with that I mean
I understandably had come I was working
at a CPG package design firm and we had
recently designed a Burger King logo and
the Star Wars Episode two Attack of the
Clones packaging and merchandising and
the Hershey bar and so you know I was
coming from a completely different point
of view we ended up disagreeing so
vehemently that at one point I thought
we were going to actually come to
fisticuffs but okay
wee little is this behind the seizures
as well yeah on the page while we're on
the panel and there's somebody that's
trailing us on writing notes for an
article that's going to appear in the
annual fortify in any case we were only
able to agree I think on seven things
that would go into the competition
Journal which is not a way to encourage
future applicants to apply for the
competition so a IJ was not particularly
happy with us this juror of mine the
fellow juror
hated me and I felt at the end of that
day that I would never ever be asked to
do anything with AIGA ever again and I
remember walking back to my office which
was at the Empire State Building at the
time it was sort of dusk and I felt like
oh this is never ever going to work out
and resign myself to that Rick asked for
some work of mind to be included in the
journal as evidence of my credentials
for being a juror and the two biggest
projects that I had done at the time
were the Burger King identity and the
Star Wars identity and so I sent those
in as my credentials they were printed
in the journal
and that was
the end of that or so I thought may 2nd
2003 I get to get a link from a friend
of mine she sends me an email and she's
like read this in the privacy of your
own home preferably with a big drink and
boy what is that up I know right and I
am NOT one that likes surprises or
anticipation I need instant
gratification so I don't wait to go home
I don't wait to get a drink I click into
the link at my desk in my office and
come to a letter an open letter to AIGA
written by a designer named Felix aqua
on this thing called speak up and speak
up was one of the first web logs and the
first design blog and the letter
chastises AIGA for including me Debbie
Millman as a juror in their annual
competition what is supposed to be the
most prestigious competition in the
country and accused me of not only being
a corporate clown but also because of
the work I do they called me a she-devil
a she-devil Wow and proceeded to take my
entire career down and it was a pile-on
so not only was the open letter quite
harsh but then there was the pylon of
comments that happened in the early days
of blogging remember that oh yeah so I'm
so glad that the hateful comments are
thing at the past but yes oh yes
infinitely infinitely right and I'm
reading this and my jaws gape and I am
just in a state of catatonia
I couldn't move I was ashamed
embarrassed terrified that people in my
office would see it that the reputation
of the firm was being sullied by me and
I didn't know what to do
I was despondent I
walking home from work that day crying
thinking that I had to quit I had to
leave the design business and I my
career was over
this career that I had finally found for
myself was now officially over and I I
honestly did not know what to do Tim I
felt like if I wrote in that it was
paint offensive that it would bring more
attention to this story I felt that if I
didn't write in that I would be missing
an opportunity to at least contribute to
the conversation with a point of view
that might be different than theirs I
didn't know what to do and looking back
on it now I'm actually really ashamed of
what I did because it was disingenuous
but at the time it was the only thing
that I felt I could do and so a few days
after the story broke and the comments
piled in I contributed and my first
comment was and you're gonna you're not
going to approve of this Oh was it I
wrote what a cool discussion I was sorry
I you know the the book cool girl had
not come out at that time but had it
been out I would have said that's what I
was trying to be I was trying to be the
cool girl nothing matters I can eat five
chili dogs and I don't gain weight you
know yes I'm quoting the book so yeah I
I came in and that's what I said but I
ended up having the the best possible
back-and-forth I could muster I tried to
talk about how we had constructed the
Burger King logo and the amount of
testing we had done around the world and
how consumers really seemed to like it
and who would they do sort of declare
that it wasn't worthy and I try to be as
as opened and as defenseless as possible
and ultimately they continue to pile on
some more insults and make fun
the practice that I that I had and then
a couple of people weighed in otherwise
and the final comment was from a man
named David Weinberg who since who has
since become friends with as well who at
the time worked at Landor and wrote in
or what is land or is a one of the
world's biggest and most respected brand
consultancy started by Walter land or
about 80 or 90 years ago and he wrote in
you know let's see what Felix could do
with that Burger King logo and great
work over there sterling and that was
some of the end of that conversation
nobody else came in with another comment
and what I thought was over really
wasn't because this is the it was the
original writer of this open letter
philosophical the illustration designer
goddess and then they I thought it was
over I thought it had ended with some
sort of a compromise and viewpoints but
to my chagrin the writers at speak up
kept writing about me and the next
article was called is the dark side
prevailing so subtle so say very subtle
at that point Tim I was obsessed I was
going to decide 1520 times a day
constantly refreshing seeing what they
were writing about me and finally gave
up and went to my IT person and fit with
parental controls on my computer at work
I don't want to be able to see this site
and he did mom's you need a helpful pair
of handcuffs yeah that was that um and
and but I don't you know I'd go home and
look but whatever
a couple weeks later the founder of
speak up a young man about 23 years old
named Armand Vint reached out to me he
wrote me an email and he apologized he
didn't apologize for calling my work a
pair of turds which is what is I didn't
realize Theresa came in pairs
it shows what I know I you and and but
he said he apologized for the bullying
and for the unprofessional way in which
the conversation ensued as opposed to he
made it very clear that he still thought
my work was a pair of turds but he
didn't feel that it was right the way
that I had been I'm spoken to and I took
a lot of care in responding to him I
accepted his apology but at the time I
was really fascinated by this whole
blogging thing it was really interesting
to me the sort of real-time
communication holding people accountable
and I wrote him this sort of diatribe
about it and he responded and said well
would you like to write for the site and
I was like whoa didn't expect that one
and I so I said yes and I started
writing for speak up and I started the
Darth Vader column well what was so
interesting about the experience Kim was
that the sort of what they were do what
the speak up words were calling the
precious design world the AIGA world
they had already rejected me and now the
renegades the anti AIGA contingent they
were rejecting me so at that moment I
actually felt like the most hated woman
in graphic design
masterless Samurai where is he exactly
so what what happened after that was it
was really surreal and this is why I say
that what felt like at the time in May
of 2003 to be the lowest point of my
professional career actually became the
catalyst upon which everything else has
been built and so I started writing for
speak up and all of a sudden I started
to have that sense of what I had been
originally searching for in my efforts
would speak up I felt like I was part of
something bigger than myself I felt like
I was part of this sort of renegade
group of misfits that were trying to
change the world through graphic design
criticism and online conversations we
all decided that year in the fall of
2003 that we were going to go as a group
of sort of guerrilla
Speak Up writers to the upcoming AIGA
annual conference in Vancouver and we
were going to give out this little
brochure that Armen had put together
called
stop being sheep which was a riff on
and the great typographer Erik
Spiekermann book stop stealing sheep
which is about letter-spacing you know
thin slicing here to the very best of
our ability and so we went with this
little brochure and we to the conference
fine so these people then ended up
accepting you the people who had
previously vilified you you know that
had previously vilified me not only
accepted me but over the years Arman and
his wife Brian II and I have become such
good friends that I am now the godmother
to their eldest daughter Wow
so sort of similar to that Robert
Edelstein story back when I was in Kyle
in in college where he rejected me or
what I thought was a rejection of me
then ultimately became one of my
lifelong friendships and now Arman and
Brian II are also family at this point
family amazing so I I interrupted the
you're on route and a group of heretics
and us and a pile of brochures or
pamphlets right brochures change in the
world you know that and I'm sitting next
to people that are also activists one
that was at that time one direct flight
from New York to Vancouver the flight is
filled with design luminaries Michael
Bay rude and Paula Scher and I'm sitting
next to a woman who is beautiful and
elegant and I'm wearing sweat pants and
carrying of a bag of McDonald's
breakfast you know and the only people
that like the way McDonald's breakfast
smells the people eating it not the
people smelling it ha ha ha ha
you know I don't know why I didn't think
that I would see people that I knew on
this plate I would say well in any case
so I started talking to this woman next
to me and turns out she's going to the
conference as well I asked her what she
does she says she's a writer at print
magazine I tell her about speak up she's
all interested in what we're doing she
gives me I tell her that we're having
this get-together this party over the
course of the conference she's I'd like
to invite her she gives me a card
without looking at it I put it into my
bag
like we have we talked through a couple
hours and then we go off into our own
thing with you know whatever else we
were doing on the flight when I get to
my room in Vancouver I take her card out
of my bag and I see that she's the
editor-in-chief choice right okay I
invite her to the party she comes and we
start a correspondence I had this I
harbored this hope that maybe I could
write for print magazine one day and a
couple of months later she writes me and
asked me if I want to participate in
something she's putting together for the
upcoming held conference the next year
in San Diego and it's be at the time
reality TV had just sort of burgeoned
into culture and it was a very popular
TV show called Iron Chef about cooking
in real time in the audience voting and
she wanted to do a riff on that called
ironic chef where three designers would
create work on stage in real time and
the audience would vote this to me
sounded like the definition of hell and
just to clarify for people print
magazine is actually called prints it is
called a grand experiment it is called
print magazine it's the oldest print
mesh the oldest graphic design magazine
in the country seventy-five years old it
has won I think five National Design
Awards General Excellence Awards for the
knot National Design Awards I'm sorry
Magazine Awards which is the highest
honor an Effie believe it's called that
a magazine can win and it was it it's a
remarkable magazine and I had the
extreme some day writing something for
it garlic chef yes ironic chef 90
buildings personal version of hell yeah
and and I'm afraid to say no if I feel
like if I say no I'm never going to be
offered an opportunity to do anything
with Joyce again so I say yes and I'm
further humiliated when I get to San
Diego by real when I realize that I have
to wear a chef's outfit onstage
there are pictures of this by the way
I'm not lying or exaggerating and so I
go through with this I am on stage with
the emcee Steve Heller who I'd never met
Steve Heller is one of the world's
foremost design critics he was the art
director of the New York Times Book
Review for 30 years he started numerous
programs at school visual arts graduate
programs and he's written about 170
books about design and graphic designers
he is the judge I am terribly
intimidated because he is the feller one
of the greatest people that has ever
lived
and there are three of us I come in
second which is not terrible I don't win
but I don't lose and I'm another a Burin
moment of courage I asked Steve if he
was nice to me that day if you'd want to
have lunch in New York City when we were
back he lived in New York City as well
he agrees we go to lunch I was so
intimidated I had a cheat sheet that I'd
prepared of topics in which I could
discuss with Steve wrote it on a paper
napkin put it in my lap and I could
refer to it if I choked and knew not
what to say next in any case I had some
book ideas Steve told me they were both
bad I went away a little bit discouraged
but still happy that I met him and he
told me that I'd get a book just to be
patient four months later a publisher
calls at the recommendation of Stephen
Heller with a book that he had turned
down they had wanted him to write with
the horrific title how to think like a
great graphic designer once again I
think if I don't say yes to this I'm
never going to be asked for anything
again and I take on this book but I
asked them if I could do it in a
different way because I didn't believe
that there was just one way for a great
graphic designer to think there were
myriad ways and could I interview great
graphic designers and reveal how they
think they agreed and that became my
first book in the meantime choice writer
K the editor of print magazine reaches
out and asks me if I'd like to write a
review about Wally Owen
then upcoming book on branding I agree I
write my first piece for print magazine
that year and I've written for every
single issue pence whoa
thirteen years later two years ago I was
appointed the editorial and creative
director of print magazine well seems
like those brochures did play a role and
that's just the start of a Tim if it
weren't for speak up and that story I
was then contacted by a fledgling
internet radio network called voice
America in 2004 shortly after a piece
that Mark Kingsley and I wrote about
election graphics that kind of went
viral and they wanted me to host a show
about branding I was worried that if I
said no I'd never get another
opportunity again and asked if I could
sort of do it about branding but maybe
do more about design and pitch this idea
to them about design matter radio
network show they said yes just when I
was beginning to think ooh I might get
rich from this they told me that I
needed to pay them for the airtime
surprise another size but I was really
excited about this and at that time you
know everything I was doing was very
commercially driven and felt that this
would be a way for me to talk about
graphic design and engage with people in
a way that had no commercial value
whatsoever it was just all about how to
satisfy sort of our souls our creative
souls and that's how design matters was
born my podcast was born on this set of
Wayne's World
esque internet radio network called
Voice America I did the show for four
years on Voice America paid them for
four years to do it and then brought the
show to design observer build rental the
the late great builder and tell the
founder of design observer invited me to
bring the show over to design observer
in 2009 with the proviso that I improve
my sound quality I was doing my show
with two handset you know that you ever
you know have a conversation with two
people
on the same phone line in your house and
you're on different handsets in
different parts of the house and echo
and all of that
those are my early shows but I had no
idea what I was doing there was there
was no podcast when I started I started
to upload my show to iTunes just the
kick of it just to be able to share it
and now twelve years later three weeks
I'm going to have my 12th anniversary of
design matters we won a cooper here at
National Design Award in 2009 at the end
of 2015 iTunes and you know this because
you're always on the list but after 11
years iTunes designated it one of the
best podcasts on iTunes and I've
transitioned the show from a show about
why design matters to a show about how
creative people design their lives and
the trajectory that people take and even
from this conversation you can probably
tell how interested I am in how people
make their lives the choices they make
and how they live and what they dream
about what they become and so that's the
the direction that the show has taken
and then about to approach my 300th
episode congratulations that's a huge
milestone and you being interested in
the in the way that you are and with the
intensity that you are interested I
think it's very well reflected in the
episodes themselves and that we've spent
some time in your studio yeah there's
one one one of the most lovely and
engaging conversations I've I've ever
had in interview format it was it was
such such a relaxed and fun experience
for me which is not the norm as as you
know so I certainly recommend everyone
check out design matters but I want to
talk about some of your decisions and
specifically we could talk for 20 hours
but I want to talk about a name that I
had not heard in my life until very
recently
milton glaser hmm yes as you'd mentioned
you'd done I guess brand makeovers or
branding for Burger King Star Wars I
think you Hershey's Tropicana I think
yes yes tell me from getting this wrong
but you know at one point if you walked
in any grocery store supermarket etc you
had a hand and say 20% of everything
that you saw something something like
that isn't that crazy
yeah knows it it's mind-blowing when you
consider the number of different
products right the SKUs and for people
who are wondering what CPG is consumer
packaged goods and so it's a point your
hand was involved in just an incredible
array and in plenitude of of different
products how did how did Milton Glaser
enter the scene and could you describe
for people who he is Milton Glaser is
the elder statesman of the design world
and is the world's one of certainly one
of if not the greatest living graphic
designer he's in his 80s he is
responsible for the I heart New York
logo he did that iconic Bob Dylan poster
of Bob Dylan in profile with the streams
of colorful hair he is one of the
founders of New York Magazine the list
goes on and on he's had more impact and
created some of the most memorable
well-known and iconic brands and
identities in the world my my
relationship with Milton really began
when I took a class of his at the School
of Visual Arts a summer intensive in the
summer of 2005 I had already interviewed
him for design matters but it was over
the phone and I well I cherished that
interview it was one of my very very
early interview so I'm still I'm
somewhat gun-shy to send people to
listen to that one because it's so early
in my journey as a broadcaster but in
any case I took this class with him and
that that class
you know it's interesting about how we
started the show talking about my
eight-year-old drawing and you talking
about your friend who had written this
essay that then predicted his life
Milton taught this summer intensive I
think for about 40 or 50 years and he
used to say that it was one of the most
important things that he did he's not
teaching it anymore he had us do an
exercise in that class where we had to
envision the life that we could have if
we pursued everything that we wanted
with the certainty that whatever it is
that we wanted we would succeed and I I
wrote an essay in May of 2000 and no I'm
sorry July of 2005 there was must be a
five-year plan and he asked us to dream
big and not to edit and said that it had
a bit of a magical quality that he
experienced with his students over and
over so to be careful what we wished for
and I created this essay with these long
ranging far-fetched goals that I can
tell you now 12 years later have almost
all come true it is spooky stinky and so
that's an exercise I do now with my
students he said Milton has had one of
the most profound impacts on my life
aside from you know the profound impact
he's had on the world I feel really
really lucky that I have been a student
of his and have gotten to interview him
now numerous times and feel that my
relationship with him is certainly one
of the luckiest things that's ever
happened to me well can you describe the
exercise as you do it with your students
now well I teach undergrad and graduate
classes at the School of Visual Arts I
run of masters and branding program at
the School of Visual Arts which I was
given this opportunity via Steve Heller
who I again would not have met had that
whole speak up experience not happen so
yet another thing every single thing
that I'm doing now in my life Tim stems
from that experience also just just
underscore another theme he had in in
some sense you could interpret it as
rejected two of your book ideas even
though he's nice to you and took and
went out to lunch with you but now later
on down the line you you kept that
relationship and lands you at SVA
absolutely I mean Steve is one of the
most generous and engaging people I have
had the privilege of knowing and I I
often tease Steve and say that he's my
fairy godfather because he's the only
person in my life or maybe one of two
people in my life now that I could say
has just been he has this sort of
generosity that is all about here take
this
do that make this happen this is for you
with no strings no ties no obligations
it's just pure generosity and he has
done that over and over and over and
over again for me since meeting him back
in 2004
so the exercise that I do now with my
students because they're quite a bit
younger than I was when I was doing this
five-year essay or a five-year plan I
asked them to do a ten year plan and so
this gives them a chance to really
mature into who they are in their 20s
and into their early 30s and it's this
ten year plan for what I call a
remarkable life and it's about imagining
what your life could be if you could do
anything you wanted without any fear of
failure and they are the most life
affirming essays they are so full of
hope and optimism and well-being and
goodness that it gives me a sense that
humanity is can be saved and so I've
borrowed that exercise from Milton and
now use that both in my graduate program
and
the undergraduate classes that I teach
it's going to seem nerdy but I'm a nerd
so I'll run with it and that is deep do
you have any parameters for people at
home who might want to try this our
recommendations ways to start is it
blitz or is it pros in full now it
exists what is that
yeah any any recommendations for people
who would like to give this system so
let's say it is winter 2027 what does
your life look like what are you doing
where are you living
who you living with get pets kind of how
see you in is it an apartment view in
the city are you in the country what are
your what is your furniture look like
what is your bed like what are your
sheets like what kind of clothes do you
wear what kind of hair do you have tell
me about your pets tell me about your
significant other do you have children
do you have a car do you have a boat do
you have talk about your career what do
you want what are you reading what are
you making what excites you what is your
health like and right this day this one
day ten years from now so one day in the
winter of 2027 what does your whole day
look like star flu the minute you wake
up brush your teeth have your coffee or
tea all the way through till when you
tuck yourself in at night what is that
day like for you dream big dream without
any fear write it all down you don't
have to share it with anyone other than
yourself put your whole heart into it
and write like there's no tomorrow
write like your life depends on it
because it does and then read it once a
year see what happens imagine
by magic and they did little national I
need to do this I'm not asking for some
hypothetical listener listeners I love
you guys but this is this is all for me
it is astounding and I do this now with
all of my students and I can't begin to
tell you how many letters I get from
students from 10 years ago that are like
Debbie it all came true
how did this happen and I am so thrilled
that these things can make a difference
and this goes back to our the earlier
part of our conversation about my own
fears about what I could or would or
should become and the idea that at that
same time in my life that intersection
on Bleecker Street and 6th Avenue
peering deep into my future and not
knowing that anything was possible for
me to give somebody at that same stage
in their life or any stage really but
particularly at that vulnerable stage
when you are so worried about what you
can or can't become to give somebody
that sliver of a dream of a hope that
this could happen and have them declare
what they want I think is a remarkable
exercise that's why I call it your 10
year plan for a remarkable life how long
was your essay and is is there any
consistency to length are there
guidelines or is it as long as it takes
and summer two pages summer 20 pages
summer two pages summer 20 pages I think
the longer it is the more likely it is
to be affirmed for some reason I find a
more generic put into it the more the
more care and detail you put in oh no no
that's that's doggy yeah that's my Molly
sir she's excited about this exercise
please game yeah clearly um I think that
the more care you put into it the likely
the more success he'll have coming out
of it mine was I wrote it in a journal
that I was keeping at the time so it was
about five by seven it was probably
about ten handwritten big handwriting
had big handwriting ten big handwriting
pages and it was the whole thing
and then because it was really excited
about it because I love lists I made a
list of everything that I wanted to come
true well I tell you I think that might
be a good place to wrap up this part one
which I think we I think we may have
more conversations in us which kind of
so many questions I'd still like to ask
but I think that is a given people have
a primacy and recency bias I want them
to remember this exercise as one of one
of the the actionable recommendations
that they can they can they can
certainly explore from this interview
and there's so much but let me ask
before I let you go the and I'll ask
where people can find you and so on
learn more about your work but before
that is there any parting piece of
advice or recommendation question
anything that you'd like listeners to
carry with them when they stop listening
to this um well let's see I recently
went through a pretty major transition
in my life and it was something that I
had to make a pretty big decision about
and it was a somewhat prolonged
agonizing decision so much so that my
friends and and loved ones were no
longer listening to my sort of
machinations and making the decisions I
thought I never was going to actually
make the decision and so I can share
that because I do think on the other
side of that decision now is an
important realization that I think can
help people I was working I have had a
full-time job since I graduated college
and for the last 22 years I was working
at a branding consultancy as I mentioned
called sterling brands
and had been very lucky to be able to
sell the company that I was a part of
and ultimately a partner in after about
13 years of working there so in 2008 the
two partners that I had the man that
have originally hired me Simon Williams
and then Austin Magee who is the third
partner to come in after me
we sold our company to Amica and at the
time I had been offered this opportunity
with Steve Heller to start the Masters
and branding program at the School of
Visual Arts and organized my time so
that my day job at Sterling brands
wouldn't be impacted by what I was going
to be doing it sa which was made
possible by starting my branding program
as an evening program so I had two
full-time jobs a day job at Sterling in
my night job at SVA and most people
thought that I would go through my earn
at Sterling and and then leave and
transition to working at SVA and doing
all of the personal projects that I had
been talking for so long about doing and
so the five years happened and we had a
really wonderful successful earn-out so
there was no excuse to him for me to
continue on the same path and it was
time to make that change and the last
thing I wanted was to end up like the
characters in Revolutionary Road that
remarkable book where people talk about
making these changes their whole lives
and then never ever do but I became
terrified I became terrified that if I
made this change that I would not have
financial stability anymore that I would
not be able to fill all the dreams that
I had and would have to confront that
and so five years turned into six years
and six years turned into seven years
and just at a point where I was starting
to think about really doing it sort of
like Al Pacino and Godfather 3 I was
offered an opportunity to take over as
CEO of the company Simon Williams the
then CEO was looking to become chairman
and needed
she will point to new CEO and he came to
me and asked if I wanted the job and
here it was this is the big decision of
a life do I become the CEO and have this
amazing continuation of money and career
and security and everything else that is
conventionally approved of or do I say
no actually I am NOT going to double
down I'm going to live the way in which
I have been saying I wanted to with more
freedom and more opportunity to do
personal projects and pro bono projects
and give back and I had a design and it
took me four months to decide Simon
Williams finally said to me Debbie
anything that takes you four months to
decide probably means you don't want to
do it and it was the hardest decision of
my life but I turned it down
I turned the CEO job down and then two
things happened first of all one of the
things that I realized was that I was in
this trapeze and rather than just let go
of the trapeze and do something else I
had every single crook of my body
holding on to some other trapeze and
that there was this sense of if I am not
doing enough I am not worthy
if I am not making enough I am not
worthy if I'm not producing enough I am
not worthy and suddenly I had to not
just let go of the trapeze but let go of
the entire apparatus and I have realized
now two things one most people live in a
world of scarcity we think that all we
have now is all we will ever have and if
we give something up we will just have
less what ends up happening is that we
don't think about all the possibilities
of things that could come up if we give
ourselves openings to receive them and
so now as opposed to having less than
when I thought I have way more because I
have all these new things that I'm doing
that I never would have thought possible
second that hard decisions are only hard
when you're in the process of making
them once you make them they're not hard
anymore
then it's just life and freedom and it's
an extraordinary experience that I
really would like to share with your
listeners with our listeners it's such
an important discussion on many levels
and I want Thank You Perry it's worth
repeating a few things and certainly the
seconds in my experience as well one
that agonizing over the decision is
often harder than whatever the outcome
of the decision will be and for that
matter if you make in many cases not all
but in many cases if you make a decision
and you decide that it's not the right
decision for you
you can quit you can do something else
it's not a permanent sentence
necessarily and also this is something
that I've had to learn and relearn many
times in my life which is if it's taken
you that long to make a decision if you
probably don't and shouldn't don't want
to and shouldn't do whatever it is that
you're agonizing over with pro and con
lists trying to justify in some fashion
it's in both of those points I think are
so so important I also think that if
you're waiting for something to feel
right before you do it if you're waiting
for a sense of security or confidence
that those things are sort of like being
on a hedonistic treadmill if you think
you need enough of this before you do
that when you achieve whatever that is
you think you need you're going to then
up the ante and you're never ever going
to be satisfied with whatever it is you
think you need before you do something
if it's not something that is real so if
you think oh I need this much money
before I do this when you get that much
money then you're going to realize oh I
actually think I need this much more and
it's just going to be this carrot in
front of you that you are in agonize
you're that you're agonizing over trying
to reach and then the other thing is I'm
going to quote Danny Shapiro here the
great writer Danny Shapiro if you're
waiting for confidence and she I asked
her once about confidence and she said
that confidence is highly highly
overrated and that most confident people
are overly confident people tend to be
kind of annoying and she said what she
felt was more important than confidence
with courage and I fully fully agree
taking that first step confidence really
only comes from repeated attempts at
doing something successfully but in
order to take that first step you need
courage and that's much more important
than confident so for anybody that's
waiting for the confidence to show up
take the first step in a moment of
courage even if it's aberrant courage to
come full circle in this conversation
that's good advice
and it reminds me of something that the
brother Kamal rava got of another friend
of mine the vollrath [ __ ] told me
involves very very successful
entrepreneur and investor among other
things very very good writer as well as
his brother Kamala just had a knowledge
amount but Duvall said to his brother if
I always did when I was qualified to do
I would be pushing a broom somewhere and
I think I was very very encouraging
JJ Debbie I have so much fun every time
we get to spend time together where can
people find out more about you where can
they learn more about your work where
would you like people to say hello and
social if that and I'll put all this in
the show notes for buddy yeah absolutely
I'm Debbie Millman on Twitter and
Instagram you can see more about my
program at the school visual arts at SVA
edu and Debbie Melanie comm where you
can listen to all my podcasts and see my
visual essays and my books and so on and
so forth for people who are not who
would be novices or new entrants into
the world of say graphic design
recognizing that your podcast is about a
lot more than that which episode or
episodes would you suggest they start
with I would suggest that they start
with
is Chris where he is an extraordinary
graphic novelist it's one of the most
favorite episodes that I've ever
conducted at 11 W a r e and from there
some of my favorite episodes over the
last year aside from my episode with you
which I cherish my episodes with Amanda
Palmer my episode with Alain de Botton
my episode with Krista Tippett Nico
Muhly the great composer those are all
episodes in the last year that I'm most
proud of wonderful Debi your rock star
they kind of don't want to check it
thank you thank you
I really created it and to everybody
listening as always you can find show
notes links to resources all sorts of
things we talked about and maybe more at
four hour work week comm forward slash
podcast and until next time thank you
for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday is that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and 500 Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that have somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode is brought to you by wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple
and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash Tim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint
and little things that you may or may
not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting rebalancing your
portfolio across more than 10 asset
classes and dividend reinvestment add up
to very large amounts of money over
longer periods of time wealth front as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low cost that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront com4
slash tim that is less than five dollars
a month to invest a thirty thousand
dollar account for instance now normally
when I have a sponsor on this show is
because I use them and recommend them in
this case it's a little different I
don't use wealthfront yes because I'm
not allowed to here's the deal
they wanted to sponsor this podcast but
because of FCC regulations companies
that invest your money are not allowed
to use client testimonials so I couldn't
be a user and have them on the podcast
but I've been so impressed by wealth
funds that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money and was forming
in the team and the company itself so I
am an investor and hope to soon use it
as a client now back to the
recommendation as
a Tim Ferriss show listener you'll get
$15,000 managed for free if you decide
to open that account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest you take two minutes fill out
their questionnaire at wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim fast free there's no
downside that I can think of this
episode is brought to you by fresh books
back in 2003 a busy freelancer named
Mike Sherman but I've actually had
dinner with accidentally saved over an
invoice and lost all this work to make
sure that never happened again Mike set
out to create fresh books which is now
the number one cloud accounting software
designed exclusively for self-employed
professionals around the world that is
used by now 10 million plus folks in
total we need to send invoices get paid
fast and track the time a lot of you
fall in that category in September of
this year Mike and his entire team
relaunched an all-new version of their
platform built from the ground up double
down on what made a great in the first
place namely simplicity and speed so I
can't cover all the features in this
particular sponsor read but you can send
a branded invoice another 30 seconds you
can see when a client's looked at their
invoice and you can enable online
payments in two clicks if you need
customer support will get a real human
being on the phone in 3 rings or less
and there are many other things you can
do take pictures of receipts on your
phone using their iOS mobile app and it
makes expenses of million times user etc
etc it is a rad service a lot of you
have recommended to me that's how this
came to be as a sponsorship so to claim
your 30-day unrestricted free trial that
means no credit card needed and see how
the brand-new FreshBooks can change your
freelancing game go to FreshBooks com
forward slash Tim and enter kim t IM in
me how did you hear about a section that
is first books comm forward slash tip
you